well let's talk to Irish aramesh who's
the international political analyst and
he joins me from Houston in Texas good
morning Irish and thanks so much for
joining us so is it as Dilma Rousseff
says a coup and a farce it's definitely
not a coup and she's using that for a
particular political purpose she comes
from she was a prisoner in the 70s
during the reign of the generals the
very generals who actually a few if you
have a coup a coup d'etat you need milk
you need the military taken over a
civilian government this is not a coup
but she's definitely employing a certain
political vocabulary who tried to incite
some excitement anger and fear in her
base that being removed unjustly from
the office now whether she's being
removed unjustly from the office or
whether these allegations are all one
hundred percent accurate and just that's
a whole different matter but it boils
down to this the country is suffering
from massive corruption her and her
government and members of a party tried
to manipulate the books by trying to
hide the actual extent of the countries
that not only her party but also the
opposition is extremely in you know neck
deep involved in corruption and forth
she did not have the skills and the
ability required to be able to manage
this situation politically as Brazil as
you know is the seventh largest economy
in the world and the largest economy in
Latin America so a rush now that tremor
is the acting president do you think he
is going to be the one who'll be able to
sort Brazil out as it were perhaps it's
not going to be something that he can
accomplish overnight and actually as a
matter of fact I'm not very hopeful
Tamara comes from a more of a centrist
political base he has a long history
with working with that with Congress
socialist members of the car we knob of
the Brazilian Congress have gone on the
record saying that he understands the
quote-unquote logic of how to deal with
congressional members in in the
Brazilian system so but his job really
is to do two things a
to keep a lid on this political fiasco
that has now engulfed Brazil in flames
and B try to jumpstart this stagnating
economy that has now been in a recession
for quite some time and there are many
many reasons for that but it is
undeniable that that the Workers Party
and the work behind the party of Dilma
Rousseff and a predecessor Lula da Silva
her mentor they actually have a
political base to our people who were
lifted out of poverty and were given
social services about a quarter of the
Brazilian population has enjoyed some of
these services some of those people
actually fear that the new president or
the acting president Tamara would cut
back some of those benefits but again
that is just one issue here the big
issue is that this large major economy
in Latin America for that matter in the
world is stagnant the currency has been
declining and it has to get a jump start
now with political uncertainty and
instability just it makes the prospects
of a better economy just much much
harder to imagine and how do you think
she's going to fare in this trial
because she does actually have a
reputation as an honest politician and
that's what makes this whole issue
rather confusing for people on the right
orford or on the left adding to that is
the fact that a large number of those
parliamentary parliament
parliamentarians or those members of the
Senate in the Brazilian Senate they are
themselves under either investigation or
indictment for corruption the the petrol
bra company a major major oil company in
Brazil that is neck-deep involved in a
lot of kickbacks and corruption a large
group of the elites in Brazil are now
accused of having been involved in a lot
of sort of under-the-table dealings and
a lot of these folks who now voted to
bring in articles of impeachment and
trial against President Rousseff are
they themselves both from the left and
the right the opposition and the
government in power are now accused of
this so it's just a very murky situation
I don't think she has much as she has a
great chance of survival unless
something changes significantly in the
political landscape especially in the
sort of a public of Penny and landscape
of Brazil as you know over sixty percent
of Brazilians won her gone okay Irish
thank you so much the international
political analyst Irish aramesh they're
talking to us from Houston in Texas